totally irresponsible people are putting
out there
about little children toddlers
learning how to use an assault weapon
smaller assault weapons but a gun like
mommy and daddy is that sick
is that sick so i don't know what guns
she's referring to i have never seen
an ar-15
in a toddler size i i've never seen that
at the gun store but she's saying it's
irresponsible that parents are
familiarizing their children
with guns and it's completely the
opposite isn't it the irresponsible
thing to do if you're a gun owner is to
not tell your kids anything about it one
day your kids are going to find them
they're not going to know what to do and
god forbid something terrible could
happen responsible gun ownership
especially if you have a family is
familiarizing your kids with these
weapons showing them
how to hold them how not to hold them
not to use them you know if mommy and
daddy aren't around and various never
don't load the gun that's the most
responsible gun ownership that there can
be